Uh, so it's really, it's an insane form,
insane form of science denialism that
I've spent 25 years fighting and I'm not
sure if I'm any closer
to winning the battle.
It's the only form of science and now
isn't, it's culturally acceptable.
It's culturally acceptable because it,
it defines people in a way that makes
them feel like animals or makes them feel
cheap or it makes them feel like
they're prostitutes, you know, makes it,
makes people feel like they're
prostitutes. And interestingly,
it comes a lot more for this particular
form of size than eyes and from the left.
This is why a lot of a lot of
people will write me and say, well,
why do you seem to be critiquing a lot
more people on the left and the right
that that's not,
that's not showing my political colors.
It's simply because the ecosystem that
I navigate in, which is called academia,
it just so happens that most of the bs
comes from the left because the academia
is laden with leftists.
Yeah.
So it's not so much that I
give a free pass to the right.
When you have a right wing
senator who denies evolution,
I'm the first to also critique him.
But the reality is when
it comes to human nature,
it's really the leftists who are denying
the biological basis of our human
nature.
Why do you think that this science
denialism is so prevalent on the last,
on the left when it comes to gender?
Because gender seems
to be the battleground.
It seems to be the battleground even in
terms of transgender, right? Uh, but the,
the,
the battleground of gender,
whether it's the gender pay gap or
whether it's traditional gender roles,
this seems to be where science denialism
it lives on the left in the more,
you know,
like
what I always grew up
thinking about the left,
the left was always more open minded.
They were supposed to be the more educated
and they were supposed to be the more
compassionate people. So
something happened and I
don't know when it happened,
but somewhere along the line,
this science denialism and then this,
for whatever reason, this idea
that if it shows any differences,
if there's any statistics or any data
that shows differences between the men and
the women,
that this is somehow,
this is somehow an example of
sexism or patriarchal tyranny,
or there's a reason for
this that's negative. So I,
I think the reason is actually quite,
quite simple. At the right wing,
folks who deny science,
it's typically for religious,
ideological reasons or
for industry, right? So,
so there is some pet ideology that is
threatening me and therefore I'm going to
deny science, right? This exact same
thing is happening with the left.
They also have been parasitized by a
quasi religion. It's called progressivism.
Okay. And I say progressivism
in quotes, right? Uh, you know,
equality of outcomes and all
the rest of the garbage, right?
And therefore to the extent that
evolutionary theory in general,
but evolutionary psychology in particular
is a threat to my quasi religion than
I will reject it.
This is why evolution deniers tend to
be on the right and evolution psychology
than hires tend to be on the left. They've
both been parasitized by religions.
They're just different religions that,
so that's a fascinating way to look at it,
that progressivism is in
fact some sort of religion.
And it makes sense if you're looking
at the science denialism aspect of it,
because you're not looking at it in
terms of an objective analysis of all the
facts and the data that's in front of you.
You're saying,
what fits this construct?
What fits this pattern of behavior
that I've chosen to adopt,
and then I have to show all the people
that are around me exactly like you
accused Sean Carroll of doing,
adopting this instead of looking
at the actual facts of this case.
Postmodernism, I think. Did you have, you
had the grievance studies folks, right?
Fantastic. Peter Boghossian. Yeah.